we are on problem number 22.
and their question is straightforward
enough what is the value of the integer
x and they tell us it's an integer
x is equal to what
so the first statement
x is prime well there are a lot of prime
integers there's actually an infinite
number of them
so that alone doesn't tell us what x is
2.
x is
let's see 31
is less than or equal to x which is less
than or equal to 37
well immediately this is useless
information because 31 and 37 are both
prime numbers as far as i can tell right
they're both prime numbers so this means
that x could be 31 it could be 37 or
let's see are there any prime numbers in
between 32 33 34 35 well they're no
prime numbers in between but could be
either 31 or 37. so it doesn't help us
much
even in used in combination i mean this
alone is definitely useless because this
is a range of six numbers and even if we
know as x is prime if we use this and
this
all we know is that x is either 31 or
37. so the answer is
e
that they're together they're not
sufficient
e
now if this was if this was a
if this was a little bit different if
this was x is greater than 31 and less
than or equal to 37 then we would know
oh x has to be 37 or if it was if this
wasn't here and this was there then we
would know that x is 31. but anyway they
didn't do that they let us give us the
option so the answer is e
problem 23
23. if p q and r are three distinct
points
do line do line segments p q and p r
have the same length
so p
q
and r
i want to know if these two lines are
the same length this is the line pq
and then this is the line pr
so are those the same length let's see
if we can figure this out
statement one tells us
p is the midpoint of line segment q r
okay p
midpoint so i've already drawn it wrong
midpoint
of
q
r so let me redraw it so it actually
that they're all they're actually all
three points actually end up being on
the same line because p is the midpoint
of q r so this is the line
this is the line
this is point q
this is point
r
so if p is the midpoint p is right there
and that tells us that this distance is
the same as this distance which also
tells us that q p
line segment q p is equal to
q is equal to p r
and that's what they were i think what
they wanted so yeah right they want to
say does pq and pr have the same length
this is pq so pq and pr definitely have
the same length so statement
one is definitely true because p is the
midpoint let's see what statement two
and i mean statement one implies that
they have to be on the same line
otherwise otherwise p couldn't have been
the midpoint let's see if statement two
is
interesting
statement two q and r
lie in the same circle with center
p
interesting
so this is saying so
a circle
with center p
center p
and q and r both lie on this circle so
q could be here i'm just picking two
random points
r could be here
so we want to know whether q whether pq
is equal to
pr right that was the question
well the definition of a circle is all
points that are equal distant from p
so r has to be the same distance from p
it's going to be one radius of the
circle away from p as q is because
they're both on the circle and they're
all equal distance from p so pr is going
to be equal to pq they're going to be
equal to each other so once again 2
alone is sufficient so the answer is
d each statement alone is sufficient
problem 24 the problems are getting a
little bit more interesting
problem 24
is the number x between
two and point seven
so
that's how we can
so if i just write it point two is less
than x
which is less than point seven that's
what they want to know
statement one
tells us that 560x
x
is less than 280. and you know you don't
have to solve this you just know that
if you this is a fairly simple equation
you just can easily solve for x and if
you can solve for x you can answer this
question so you actually don't have to
go through the trouble if you want to
you can then just divide both sides by
560 but that takes time valuable time
when you're taking the gmat
and that is equal to one-half right 28
over 56
right is one-half and then you would say
sure x is between the two numbers
but you didn't have to do this that's a
wasted time problem too all you have to
do is say oh i could solve for x so i
can test that whether that's true or not
part 2 statement 2 says 700x is equal to
700x is equal to 280. same thing you
just look at you're like oh i could
solve for x if i can solve for x i can
tell you whether x is between those two
numbers and that's the end of it and you
say oh each of these independently are
sufficient to answer this question
but if you wanted to prove it to
yourself and see if this question is
true or false you can just say well x is
equal to
what
280 over
that is equal to
what is that 2.8
over 7
that is equal to 0.4 i just
divide the top and the bottom by 7 and
you get 0.4 so
once again it is between it you got you
answered the question but you remember
the question doesn't have to be
affirmative you just have to figure out
if the data is enough to answer the
question and we didn't have to go
through this and this you could have
just looked at and said i can solve for
x in either way and then just test it
next problem
i'll do it in move
25 if i and j are integers
is i
plus j
even
i plus j even
so the statement number one is that i is
less than ten
that tells me nothing i that to me that
that seems kind of useless
statement number two
is i is equal to j
i is equal to j well that's interesting
so what's i plus j then going to be
equal to well that's the same thing as
since i is equal to j that's the same
thing as j plus j
which equals 2j
or you could say you know if you
substitute j for i or if you substitute
i for j that's the same thing as i plus
i which is equal to 2i either case you
immediately see that either of these
numbers are multiple of 2 and therefore
have to be even because i and j are
integers so statement 2 alone is
sufficient and statement 1 is useless
problem 23 let me go brighter color
26 problem 26 we're on
26.
n
plus k
is equal to m
what is the value of k
so we could solve for it we
if we could answer this
because k is equal to m minus n and that
will solve our answer let's see if one
and if the statements give us any help
n is equal to 10
n is equal to 10. well that'll just tell
us that k is equal to m minus 10. it
still doesn't tell us what k is because
we don't know what m is
statement number two
m plus 10 is equal to n this is
interesting
m plus 10
is equal to
n
so this tells us that
what does this tell us so let's see if
we can if we can figure out from this
statement what m minus n is
then we're in business
so let's see let's subtract n from both
sides you get m
minus n plus 10
is equal to zero
subtract 10 from both sides you get m
minus n is equal to minus 10.
well we know that k is equal to m minus
n
m minus n is equal to -10 so this is
equal to k
so we solved for k using just statement
two alone
just statement two alone is sufficient
and statement one is i mean it kind of
gets us halfway but you really don't
need it statement two is all you need so
that is
b
see if we have time for
one more yeah sure why not
they have drawn a triangle for us
i'll draw it quick and dirty
see
and this this is angle x this is angle z
and this is angle y
and they want to know is the
is this triangle equilateral which means
are all the sides equal to each other so
statement one tells us that x is equal
to y
so we break out a little bit of our
eighth or ninth grade geometry here
so if x is equal to y if these angles
are equal to each other
what that tells us is that these sides
are equal to each other the
corresponding sides are the same i could
actually redraw this triangle like this
maybe
it'll jog those neurons from ninth grade
if this is x
this is y
and this is z and you could test it out
if you don't believe me and we've gone
over this in the geometry module if x
and y are equal to each other
then these sides have to be equal to
each other and you could just try to
imagine drawing a triangle that has two
base angles equal to each other and the
sides are different because it would be
impossible the sides would have to be
the same this triangle would have to be
at least isosceles and and maybe
equilateral isosceles two sides being
the same
but that by itself
doesn't tell us that this is an
equilateral triangle in order for this
to be equilateral z has to be the same
as x and y they all have to be and if
they're all going to be the same they
all have to 180 they'll have to be 60
degrees so you know you could have a
situation where x and y are both i don't
know 20 degrees if this is 20
this is 20
then they add up to 40 and then z would
have to be 140. so this doesn't and in
which case we would not have an
equilateral triangle so one alone is not
sufficient let's see what statement 2
tells us statement 2 tells us z is equal
to
z is equal to 60 degrees
so that by itself
so first of all we know if we have if we
know both of these pieces of information
we are definitely dealing with an
equilateral triangle because think about
it if z is 60
if z is 60
so if we use this and then we use this
information to know that these two are
equal to each other what do we know if z
is 60 then these two added together have
to so x plus y
plus z are going to be equal to 180. if
z is 60 then x plus y have to be equal
to
subtract z from both sides or subtract
60 from both sides has to be equal to
120 and since these are equal to each
other x and y both would have to be
equal to 60 degrees right so if you use
both of them for this information all of
the angles are going to be 60 degrees
and it's equilateral
so we know that definitely com
in combination we can figure it out
but what about just if z is equal to 60
well i can easily draw a triangle that
disproves
that so if i have a 60 degree angle here
in fact
it might be a 30-60-90 triangle like you
learned in school so you could be 60
degrees
30 degrees
and 90 degrees
and this could be z
and this definitely is not an
equilateral triangle and so if just by z
being 60 degrees in no way are you
saying that this is definitely an
equality triangle you have to have the
other condition that x is equal to y and
so the answer is
let's see
c both statements together are
sufficient but neither statement alone
is sufficient so the answer is c
see in the next video